if you're critical of his brand if
you're critical of his art the immediate
turn is oh you're just homophobic you
don't like because he gay let's actually
unpack the [ __ ] records
let's unpack the visuals they're not
they're executing their weapons are fire
but but they're executed well but he's
not making ground
i mean the video with the devil was kind
of crazy that's not even making ground
we've seen that before right but what it
is is he's just wrapping it up in gay
face like how bird williams is wrapping
up that's fair like burt williams
wrapped it up in black and he's a bird
so he's wrapping it up and he's doing
britney spears in gay face i like
pat net gay face gay face he's just gay
like black face he's gay face
so he's just over dragging some [ __ ]
right he over dragging and it's like
that shower scene is christina aguilera
that's they shot that before that that's
been done but you just used a bunch of
gay black men you just did it in gay
fights because he's a gay guy but no but
it's not because he's a gay guy he knew
everybody would care about that see gay
people ain't just running around just
being extra just like black people ain't
it's black people that's dark as black
face right it's just dark ass people
with red lips
right but people ain't just running
around just being a [ __ ]
you know we actually it's not as simple
right so when you see a black man right
that's what makes his think he's a gay
man but because he's
unbelievably at a thousand
we're trying to tell you i'm gay bro we
know you are
i'm not saying nothing wrong nobody give
a [ __ ] elton john's gay
right
all kind of people we end up loving is
gay nobody [ __ ] cares like right you
sure you care a little bit prince was
probably bisexual i think everybody
knows that but and on the same token
is it not like
it's his art right so if he wants to be
a trailblazer for his his community that
you know he's really trail that's not
trouble no i i think i think if you
think about it's like saying burt
williams is trailblazing blackface for
black because but i don't know who burt
williams is he's the f he's the biggest
you told me who's black so again
i wouldn't call him a trailblazer cause
you're not gonna have generations of no
no i just mean in terms of like i can't
think of a time
in the last 25 to 30 years that i've
been alive and paying attention to music
that there's been an openly gay
superstar
not talking about adam lambert or
somebody who
don't really matter i'm somebody super
little nazis superstar and
and what i so you and i had a discussion
about that video with the devil sure and
what i appreciated about the video was
his explanation for was essentially
everyone yeah my whole life was she said
i'm going to hell blah blah blah blah
blah all this clown [ __ ] well really it
was just like this is a good idea to
make people talk and it worked
but again again
i can isn't that a lot of this [ __ ]
though yeah but isn't that a lot of this
[ __ ] i agree 100 but then it got to be
good at the it got to be great at the
root see the great at the root to you
isn't it right at the root to maybe a 17
year old kid who loves literally we all
love great records i'm but what i'm
saying is i think little knives x has
some records that are i'm i hear a
grimlock what you mean your damn lie old
town road is best record and you know it